many mobile marketing services change
and morph on a weekly basis
in this lesson i identify five core
services that have proven to be
effective throughout the many changes in
mobile marketing
see why sms is extraordinarily powerful
and why location-based services are
among the most exciting
use these mobile services to drive
engagement and loyalty with your biggest
fans
now this list is by no means exhaustive
and it literally changes year to year
and one of the big lessons that i want
to
get across is that we need to stay
current when it comes to mobile
these five areas are those that are
performing strongest
at this time and i really feel that
these are big buckets that are going to
stand the test of time
and they are i'll walk through each of
them but they are
sms or text messaging
mms which is messaging with rich media
location location-based services
which arguably is the most exciting and
the one that is morphing more than any
other
the mobile web
and also apps
first off let's discuss sms or text
messaging
now i have been working for two mobile
marketing companies
and we primarily have sms as our core
service offering
i will tell you somewhat defensively
that sms is the least sexy of activities
but it is also in my view one of those
that really belongs on most programs
and that is because as i mentioned in
the overview people are texting on a
regular basis
well over 80 percent of those who have
mobile devices
text daily
and we have an ability to use sms
in our marketing campaigns to engage
with consumers to sell more stuff
and to opt people in to loyalty clubs
so sms stands for short message service
although nobody ever calls it that
you'll either hear it referred to as sms
or text messaging
and it is 160 characters at a maximum
now that is
by definition unsexy
and if i were talking to an agency a
room of creatives
we hear that this is the uncool way to
market through mobile
but in examples like ford that i
referenced and many others we can point
to a cause and effect of having somebody
responding to a call to action leading
to redemption in the store
and i i like to look back
in one of the more challenging winters
that we had recently there was the polar
vortex which was a term we had not heard
of previously
and lo and behold text messaging had
people come out of their homes come out
of their offices to go redeem quick
service restaurant offers for a discount
sandwich or free set of fries now i was
fortunate enough to be on the west coast
at the time
but speaking to enough of my friends and
colleagues i didn't think that anything
was had the ability to move folks but it
just goes to show you that sms is
one of those activities
that people take a look at and they take
action upon
also
i don't know about you but people are
rude when it comes to
when a text comes in
i'm certainly guilty of that and i've
been called on that i've had friends who
will text me in the middle of a
presentation and i will look down on it
i will totally lose my train of thought
but the the the positive side to that as
a marketer is that people are looking at
text messages on a regular basis within
four minutes over 96 percent of text
messages are read so this really breaks
through that clutter and some of the
other ways we can reach people through
email or through something else that
they may not see in a timely fashion
now how sms works
very simply you
engage with a
an entity that provides a short code now
a short code is a five or a six digit
number think of it like a url
and you could either have a unique code
or you can share that short code with
another business or other businesses
and that becomes your identifier so if
you are macy's you have a five this five
digit short code
and you provide all sorts of what are
called keywords to initiate campaigns
so you might have the keyword fashion
star
and you would ask somebody to text that
in to the macy's short code to initiate
an engagement and that might lead to an
offer back of a discount on product that
might lead to a link to a video and like
here's a good use of sms text marketing
clear china los angeles is the largest
radio station in the world
and way back early in the early days
2007 2008
clear channel la decided that its
consumers had a best opportunity to
engage with the station through text
so rather than call the url out every
time the dj has a promotion
it created an identifier it created a
short code it has this five digit number
and that was the way and remains the way
for consumers to primarily engage with
the station now they did it for two
reasons they did it for
advertising reasons and for engagement
reasons for the station
and at clear channel it's really
important to get people to listen to the
station more often than they normally do
it's called time spent listening
so if you opted into the clear channel
la mobile vip club through this short
code
and you said you wanted to know when
britney spears
new song was being played you would be
texted that information maybe she's in
the studio maybe her album has come out
and that would create this opportunity
for you to listen to the station at a
time you wouldn't normally and it would
be gold for the station called tsl
time spent listening
clear channel did not ask advertisers to
go get their own short code they took
into account that the clear channel la
short code was already on people's
phones
and they allowed advertisers to run
radio spots that became interactive an
example is the introduction of a new
drink at coffee bean tea leaf
and you could text in the word bean to
the clear channel la
short code
you would get a simple text message back
you would take it to um to the coffee
bean
location and the barista would make two
uh two drinks and charge you for one
very simply uh short codes become uh
one of those kinds of things that is
listed on your other marketing materials
and it's just another path for people to
find you and to engage with you
[Music]
hey want to become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simply
learn channel and click here to watch
more such videos to nerd up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here